[Music]
let's go to sarah in grand
junction colorado sarah what's going on
how are you
i'm really nervous i get nervous and
regular phone calls so
my heart is jumping out of my chest
right now lucky for you this is not a
regular phone call
this is just some knucklehead on a
podcast or on the youtube
so it's good easy for everybody so
what's up
um so the gist of my question is i'm
i wanted to get some objective advice
whether it's time to just move on
or if i write that letter and reach out
to my family again
okay walking through so
details is uh when i was three years old
my
father killed my mother and my eldest
sister wow
and so we went yeah so me and my
siblings went to live with my
aunt uncle and their children how many
kids how many kids do they have
they had four were you in the home when
your mom was
murdered i i was okay
and uh you know i i have vague memories
of that day but uh
you know i was three years old so it was
you know that
it's just very vague um but anyway so
um there was always like a difference
between us like
you know that their children called them
mom and dad but we called them by their
first names and it's kind of just
there was always kind of this hierarchy
and class difference
in the home of course yeah man and uh
yeah and so i was the youngest by
six years so i everybody had moved out
and i was alone with them for quite some
time
and so i'm going through you know the
teenager phase and
i can't even remember what happened but
said something that my cousin didn't
like and
they he told me that i was going to end
up in prison just like my father
and uh obviously that made me extremely
upset to be compared to like somebody
that uh
murdered my my mother and my sister yeah
and uh i
so my uncle pulled me aside and we went
on a little hike to
clear our head and he admitted to me
that he looked
me but not like one of his own children
and i just feel like i never really got
past those words
and i didn't know what to do at this
point um
i and how old are you now sarah i'm 29
and so that was like part of the problem
is it's been so long
and i thought i was long gone over this
you know like i'd done the work
i had gotten past it started a new life
made new friends made a new
you know my my family with my friends
and
i don't know why it's bothering me again
it makes me feel
i don't know childish and that brings me
i don't know shameful feelings and it
just makes me feel
stupid and weak that this is bothering
me again
do do you have any idea as to what set
this
this what brought these memories back
are you are you dating somebody and uh
my father was released from prison this
last september
and i think that did i don't know kind
of bother me but
i am getting uh married next month okay
and it's just like you know he's got all
his side of the family and i got
uh you know my siblings are gonna be
there but uh
you know my brother's gonna have to walk
me down the aisle there's just
you know there's differences yeah
so you may have
quote unquote gotten over this um
your body has not your body's been
carrying this for a long time
and it's all stuff that three-year-olds
should never ever see
and it experienced things that three and
four and five and six and
eighteen-year-olds should
never ever experience
no child ever should be told by a family
member
you know i like you but i don't love you
as much as them
you should have never heard those words
and i'm sorry that somebody said that to
you
yeah it's i think it's just it's made me
feel like this feeling of like an
unwanted
puppy is just like like been in the back
of my mind all my life
that's exactly right how have you over
the last
you know 20 years how have you
filled that that hole
uh you know i moved kind of just ran
made new friends made new relationships
and
you know we definitely some um
some alcohol and stuff like that but i
have a better grasp on that stuff now
now it really is just you know
every once in a blue moon i don't have a
problem but there was definitely moments
in years where i did yeah
so here's the hard truth
and then i'll give you some light at the
end of the tunnel okay
your dad murdering your mom will never
make sense
there will never be a moment when you go
oh okay
not being welcomed by your aunt and your
uncle
will never make sense
nothing anybody can say unless your
uncle was to call you
and tell you i was so wrong and i'm
sorry you were a beautiful baby i'm so
glad i got to be your dad
um
like that will never make sense you'll
never go
okay you can wrap your head around it
that your uncle was ashamed
and heartbroken and went from his own
four kids or three kids to suddenly he
has seven kids
it doesn't matter you were six
right and so the heartbreaking part of
all this
is healing will not come from answers
and clarity
you have that you have all the answers
your dad did an unspeakable evil act
your uncle committed an unspeakable evil
act
right yeah
and it just uh you know it's like hold
on hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on sorry you are so good at
man you are good at what oh here it
comes
and you can take a hard right turn and
get out of a painful situation quick
right
yeah yeah you gotta just sit in this for
a second
healing won't come from answers and
clarity it will only come from moving
forward
and so if you think of your life as a
as a story
that there's you've got some ugly hard
sentences in your story
dad killed mom period
uncle told me i was less than period
cousins made fun of me period
i let some guy take um try to fill a gap
i let alcohol fill gap i made a bad
decision whatever
period and what we all want to do
and you've got you've got trauma i can
never imagine
that 99.9 of the listeners of this could
never wrap their head around
but what we all do with trauma is we
have that pin in our hand and what we
want to do is go back and try to edit
those sentences over and over and over
and you can't
they've got peers at the end of them
what you can do the only thing you can
do
is write something different
right and so
yeah at some point you gotta let that
you gotta write that three-year-old girl
letter and let her know she never should
have seen that
and it was wrong and you gotta let that
little six-year-old girl
know that she's beautiful and fun
and got dealt a really crappy set of
cards
and then she got some help from somebody
and they didn't play well
and then man as you step into these new
life adventures this will happen as you
get married
it happens dad's coming out of jail your
body sounds the alarms again
and what healing is going to look like
for you is recognizing
oh that's what that is my body's trying
to keep me safe again
my body's trying to keep me safe because
there's a murderer on the loose now
my body's trying to keep me safe from
people who've hurt me in the past you
know it hurts me the worst family
the one thing that keeps us well has
been
a nuclear bomb in your heart and mind
and so you're in you're leaning back
into the one thing that was so was
torture to you and your brain and heart
are trying to say hey we remember this
script and it didn't go well
and that's when you have to remind your
body and your heart and your mind i hold
the pen
and i get to write what comes next tell
me about this person you're marrying
he's great uh we we are very much on the
same level
we we have a lot of silly fun together
and it is
it's been very fun hold on is he safe he
is
you trust him i do
and do you recognize you're entering
into a covenant
that the first woman that you ever knew
that covenant right
ended up tragic okay
so every time those alarms go off for
you
just drop your shoulders and say thank
you for trying to keep me safe i've got
it from here
right when you have a kid your first
beautiful little baby those alarms are
going to set off again
and that's you know i got it i got it
thank you
we're safe because my brother's awesome
and my other brother's awesome
and my sister who i don't know how many
brothers that you got they're awesome
they've been there right or died they're
gonna walk you down the aisle
is that the way you drew it up nope is
that the reality of the world you live
in yep
so we're not going to try to edit the
past we're going to write the story of
the future
and i do think at some point you're
going to have to write those kids a
letter
and let them off the hook because
they're still fighting for your hard
hard heart
right yeah
you know so what do you say i i honestly
i don't even know if my uncle
realized what he said hurt me you know
or if he was just uh
that was just the way that his brain
worked so i i just i never knew if i
should share with him
what that actually did to me or if i
should just let it
let it go i think you should put that
brick down
i i don't know what letting him know
would accomplish
me either i don't know what he's going
to be able to tell you
that will make you go okay good
you know what i mean yeah
and so as a part of your healing if you
want to talk to him and you have that
type of relationship with him now go for
it a punitive grenade throw
won't help you it just causes more
bodies
right yeah and forgiveness
is often one-sided your decision to say
i forgive you was was your uncle your
dad's brother or your mom's brother
my dad okay
so your dad was your uncle was dealing
with so much garbage
did not have the tools did not expect to
have what happened and then
man just let you down and at the same
time
hey let's be fair at the same time gave
you a roof and a house and food right i
mean
did the things to keep you where you
needed to be right
and so um as i heard once i lo you got
to blame fairly
right he got you from point a to point b
man a lot of scars along the way
and i can only imagine he was dealing
with his own trauma all that to say is
your story moving forward is not about
him
and as i'm sitting here trying to
unravel it for you it does it's of no
value
right now if you need him to say the
words i love you
go ask him but be ready if he says no
right
yeah i don't think it it's worth it at
this point i just uh
i wasn't sure if i was taking the easy
route or not i couldn't tell if i just
wanted to
let it go and uh sarah there's just
there is nothing out
there is no easy road here
there's not every road is a hard road in
this situation
and who's judging if you find an easy
road take it
right there's there is no
you've been through enough we've been
through enough
and so what i want you to do as best you
can is begin to look
forward not backwards and that's hard
because what you experienced was
evil and hard and and just
disaster but you got some other
knucklehead boy ahead of you saying hey
you're the one i want to hitch my wagon
to and i love you
can he trust you enough to be silly with
you
and he said you're you're you're my
you're my gal
and you said all right i'm in right
yep and the way you can make meaning
moving forward
is that you weren't welcomed everyone in
sarah's life is going to know that
they're welcome
nobody will out hospitality sarah
and when your little kids are born no
kid on earth will have
ever understood love like your kids are
going to understand it
right exactly that was very therapeutic
john i was nervous but
thank you so much for your help well
thank you for calling and trusting
me with this story and i want you to
know your story is going to benefit
and be a gift to
anyone listening to this and very again
very few of us are going to experience
what you experienced but we all are
wrestling with
how do we go back and deal with old
trauma and then how we move forward
and it's almost always both and
right it's almost always both in i'm
sorry that you went through that
but you have shown resolve and strength
and
bravery and
compassion for yourself for this new
person
man you're a really special person and
i'm glad that the world gets to hear
your story
and more importantly when you
begin to find value in you and say you
know what three-year-old you should
never have seen that i'm sorry
you know what six-year-old
seven-year-old i'm sorry you know what
dad i'm not carrying your trauma anymore
that was on you hey uncle aunt there
wasn't something wrong with me
there was something wrong with y'all
and y'all are experiencing your own
drama so thank you for the bed thank you
for the food
and i'm gonna go make my new life now
hey and brother thank you for stepping
in thank you for being the dad i didn't
have
thank you for being willing to walk me
down the aisle it's not the picture i
drew up but it's the picture i got
and now i'm gonna go make meaning of
this
and you're playing a long long game
sarah a lot of us who experience dramas
kids are playing long games
because we're going to heal for ourself
but we're going to heal for ourselves so
that
our kids have an entirely different
different system those bricks in our
backpack
we take them out and they pave a brick
path that's what legacy is right that
paves a road
that our kids can walk on that we can
walk on that our neighbors can walk on
the kids in our community can walk on
that we're never going to meet
because we did the hard work of getting
those bricks out of our backpack saying
i'm not carrying that crap anymore
you're brave and you're awesome sarah
thank you so much for the call